[Music]
Bonjour everybody I'm Heidi Klum and we
are in Perry high we'll be interviewing
Tim Gunn and Tim Gunn we'll be
interviewing me with questions
pre-written by et here we go question
number one
I hope I'm ready welcome to making the
cut
tell everyone what is making the cut all
about and what makes us different well
making the cut is all about finding the
next great global fashion brand and this
is a conversation that goes well beyond
design it's really about marketing and
public relations and resourcing and
production and these designers get to
sell into the world we're going into 200
countries ladies and gentlemen well
that's a very good point exciting for
these designers because for the first
time they actually get to spread you
know their work out into the world so
you know once someone at home is loved
what they've seen you know they can
swipe up and buy it right then and there
well what do we call this
there's no name for it the birth canal
what are the stakes what are the stakes
I love steak frite what are the stakes
what are they gonna get okay everyone
buckle up they're gonna get one not $1
they're gonna get 1 million dollars boom
1 million dollars your truth starlets
yes thank you Amazon we wanted to have a
private plane so we could fly around the
world but you know private plane or can
the designers have 1 million dollars at
the end so they said yes so they want a
million dollars Thank You Amazon because
with this money it's I mean it's a game
changer for these designers they can
actually make a brand make labels buy
things and just you know because it's so
hard for designers they sell something
everything goes back into making more
clothes and here they have finally you
know money to really make their brand
but they can't relax they've gotta move
move move be honest why did you want to
work with me again
Heidi there isn't a day and in the world
when I wouldn't love to work with you I
dream of working with you and there was
a moment when I thought good heavens my
time with Heidi is over and look what's
happened we've been reborn in this
fabulous new show and this whole new
context and with Amazon and Sara's back
and it's it's it's a dream that's come
true because we're like an old married
couple an old married couple that still
loves each other like we've been married
for years and years and years and we
still love each other we love each other
do you think about me the last thing
before you go to sleep and then am i the
first thing you think about when you
wake up in the morning you're the last
thing I think about and the first thing
and the middle thing and the 3/4 thing
all of it
I like do you still get nervous yes I
get terrified too like already when I
see all those chairs over there and
they're gonna be like as action I'm
gonna like do you have that too
I get Schmidt see fingers I catch fit
see everywhere there anything that
people would be surprised to learn about
me
what would they be surprised about I
don't know that you're an amazing fencer
oh well thank you I'm getting better I
think you're very good friend sir
and that mr. gun is not very good dancer
but a very good fencer on guard so Tim
what would be the one thing that people
would be surprised to know about me that
they don't know well I was about to say
that you're a fabulous singer but I
think people know that you know I people
ask me all the time what's Heidi Klum
really like and I tell them the
following I say all we need to know
about Heidi is that every crew member
adores her crew members do not suffer
fools gladly and there is not a divas
bone anywhere in Heidi's body I bring
them German pancakes in the morning when
I show up it's an old trick but that's
what I say thank you if you only could
choose one word what would be the word
to describe the Heidi Klum brand it's
Zoo blows I like that give me another
one keep it coming
heart-stopping I love parts nothing all
right I'm gonna return that question to
you yeah
what would the Tim with the Tim Gunn
Brown thing gentlemen oh thank you
let's hope class act I'm very
appreciative thank you
[Music]